this is the moment alexander cardinale
finally held his biological daughter
four months after she was born
but to meet this little girl he had to
give away a child that he and his wife
had already bonded with losing the birth
child that you know
for the genetic child that you don't
even know yet
it's a truly impossible nightmare
and daphne had to accept that the baby
she carried for nine months was not
biologically hers
instead of breastfeeding my own child
i breastfed and bonded with a child i
was later forced to give away the
cardinales are suing their fertility
doctor illeran moore they're also some
in his clinic his lab and the surgical
center where the ivf procedure took
place back in 2019
the couple's despair began in the
delivery room when they were given a
child they didn't recognize and who
looked nothing like their older daughter
a genetic test at three months old
revealed the child was not theirs
the embryo had been switched with
another couple the children born just a
week apart
the couple's lawyer says the
multi-billion dollar fertility industry
needs more regulation
fertility centers are almost entirely
unregulated
barber shops and nail salons are subject
to far tighter state and federal
regulation fertility experts dispute
this
we're inspected every two years by the
college of american pathologists these
are high-end inspections they look at
every single detail of every single
procedure that goes on as for the
cardinalis they say they're still
adjusting to raising a new child
the daughter we raised and bonded with
was gone
after months of love and affection
the lawsuit won't reverse their grief or
buy back precious moments lost but they
hope it could save others the heartbreak
schmann freeman powell sky news